哈啰同学们大家晚安
哈啰哈啰我调整一下这个麦克风的这些相对位置应该都OK啦
来那个啊我上礼拜刚从日本回来
结果回来以后这两天好像有感冒还怎么样
那也不知道是在飞机上传染到还怎么样反正就感冒了
所以这两天我是根本就没有在看盘
也没有在下单
所以我直接说我今天所有的交易碰都没有碰
因为就人不舒服
ok
所以有一些上礼拜四礼拜五底下的那些好点
我完全没有吃到一方面人在日本
那我看到旁边同学的问题
我就直接先来回答
先例如说像这个
同学说出一流一的话
第一口的赚赔比大概是多少会出
第二口的赚赔比大约是多少适合
我没有办法知道你做的交易刻度
所以我只能用涂鸦的方式来画给你看
例如说我今天碰都没有碰出手是零
假设你是吃在
例如说你吃在这个点
今天这个开盘价的这个点
画比怎么那么粗
我调整一下
来假设你吃在这个点
那你吃在这边
这边当初的这个价格是28930
然后这里是29040
所以我就知道930做到980
才一根的15分K
假设你是做15K
那其实这样我觉得没有什么意义
所以我可能会等到
可能这里到这附近
我才会当做我的第一个短单
我会用我使用的刻度
它走了几根的这个概念
如果说你是用1K
那就完全不一样的事情
因为1K可能花了15根才上去
那我应该就走了
因为是当时这个区间的这里
区间的上缘跟下缘
这样好不好
就看你用哪一个刻度
所以我无法讲
但是从赚赔比的角度来看
这里大概都是1比可能少说了4或是5短单大概4或是5所以假设亏100块你理论上你的短单要赚个400 500
这样子
然后如果你亏100块
你的长单少说4500的一倍吧
就这个是一个基本吧
不然怎么叫长单呢
所以如果从用比例来说
1比4比5大概是一个短单的距离
通常也会在这附近遇到一些压力
但偶尔压力远一点点
可能让你到1比6 1比7
甚至1比10就一个短单
偶尔啦
那偶尔你的长单可以拉得更远
这个是跟市场的情况有关
所以通常我是这样子讲
一个长线大概就是1比
也不是真的长线
就是你这个刻度
该要有的这个第二口的这个距离
大概就是1比10上下
因为你多出来的这些超额的利润
是拿来让你下一次承受亏损用的
这样子
我们一直都是做这件事情
就是赔赔赔赔赔赔赔赔赔赔赔赔
那多赚的就是拿来让我们在之后
可以承受亏损以外
还有利润留下来
他就是在这样子
好
那
我看到这个我讲一下
公司可以认购的股票打市价八折
如果是我会想买吗
既然是打八折
那代表我一买进去
我其实就比人家多赚20%
对不对
那为什么不买
买啊
那我的防守就是什么
如果我这20%被我赔掉
假设行情就下来了
我因为职务之变
我所占的这个利的20%被我赔掉
就回家了
反正就是公司送我的这个就没了
那就用掉了吧
你懂我意思吗
因为打八折啊
你等于是一只股票
假设台积电好了
你用台积电的角度来看
2500的台积电
打八折是2000块
扣掉了500点
可以哦可以哦
用这种角度来想
你就买啊
好不好
那但是
某个程度来说
你要稍微想一下这个认购的时间点如果那只股票的认购时间点我亲自参与过一只我就不讲哪一只股票熟悉的同学可以自己打字上来
我亲自参与过一只股票
它正好在我任职
在那个公司的时候上市
那上市大家买的价格
其实后来有赚
上市后一段时间
喷到这个地方去
在这个地方董事长就出来讲话
说我们业绩超棒
什么什么的
结果从这个之后后来就下来了
好不好
当初认购大家的价格大概在这附近
后面其实上市以后是有赚的
这样
OK
台子跟小纳豆明显破翻
但是已经过了
台子的破底翻有点歪歪的怎么看
好我们看一下台子
我们看一下台子期
哈哈哈哈
你认识
有同学说我高档现成员工认股
你就空单进去了
哈哈哈哈
你们家小朋友想到我之前养的短脚猫
你们是想看猫吗
那等一下我call人抱进来
还是我出去把猫抱进来好不好
大家要看猫吗
我先看到台子棋好不好
台子棋的破底范其实很明显
对不对
这里
对吧
那已经过了
的确过了
那我现在怎么看
我现在不怎么看
因为我现在看的是
这边
这里是高点
对吧
然后
如果这样讲
如果我是买在这边
我不会短出
因为我的计划是把这一段给嘎爆
现在是8月4号而已
还包含在换月月底月初的这个概念里面
因为我们以前讲摩台结算
就是外资其实他们很大部分的部位
其实不是打在台子期
他们很大一部分的部位
是打在我们讲摩根台子期货
那个时候最早期早期我们都是看那边
那他的结算日是每月倒数第二个交易日那倒数第二个交易日今天是这个月的第二个交易日然后上礼拜的这两天就是7月的倒数两个交易日
所以简单的说他的起跑点就是在那个破底翻的位置
对吧
我的同学是回答上面那位20帕的同学
OKOK
来
那如果是这样子这样子讲
我会想要把这一段
我希望今天明天就这样子把它尬上去
那我的小娜那边
因为我去日本这段时间
加上回来这样
我小娜那边之前打瓶被洗掉之后
我就完全空手到现在
一方面垂心肝
觉得哇那个低点很好吃
没吃到啊
然后能怎么办
那如果我是
我吃在这个我不会走
我认为这个角度
来你看一下这个角度
下面写写的上面平平的
请问这个力量谁比较强
这个应该一看就知道了
对吧
所以我其实在等待什么
等待某个冲出去的力量
然后把大家的这个部位带上去
我也还有台湾的现货
现货的一些电子股
什么股金融股那些我都还有
所以我其实也是期待
他就是这样子上去
期待不成功了
没关系
反正你买的位置是在很漂亮的
我這邊調查一下
這兩天在底下的這個小10k的這個破底翻
你有畫出這條線的舉手一下
就是你有把這邊
然後跟這裡
這裡跟這裡這裡這裡這些地方
你有把它這樣子拿來看說
哦這邊可以看的舉手
應該不會太難吧
你前幾天來到這邊的時候
甚至這個下影線來到這裡
你就會知道說
這裡有一個東西
這樣子
對吧
对啊!这个很美啊!好多同学都有对不对
我们就不用教了!各位换你们上来讲就好了
你们都会了!这个真的是一个很基本的
最下面这边其实有一个,这个就是我说我错过很美的点
这个!这个!这个是我人在日本的时候发生的事情
那时候我后来有看到他
哇那个点有够美
有够美
这样
好不好
来那我继续看旁边的聊天
所以其实旁边同学蛮厉害的
我有看到一些我就先截起来
我等一下再慢慢的看
因为有一字比较多
最近台股连几天都涨
跌升的跌340%的涨回一些还是没有图
选不到标的
没关系你就等啊
例如说我最近所知道
最近我所知道有一些
AI相关的股票其实最近都跌升
例如说我们用日线
这个我先拉到旁边去
我记得有一支最近跌身
好像人家有涨到多少
这算跌身了吧
从240
跌下来跌身了
但如果你拉到周线来看
就是这个跌身好
只是你要重新的在这边等待一下就好
之前涨到这个地方的时候
我还记得
我忘记我哪一次直播
我还有提醒过同学
说这边出现这样尖尖的上引线
我要注意哦
满足区边界以外
上引线尖尖的朝外
这个讲到烂掉了
然后你看就从这边咻就这样跌下来
大家记不记得前一段时间
大概在6月中旬的附近
你问到我各种AI股
然后我都会说好懒哦
就大概行情都在这个地方
然后我都提醒大家说
懒懒的我不想做
要提醒哦
就是觉得那边的样子不太对
当时的图很多都是这样子
然后冲一根回来
然后很多在这个地方鬼混
大概在这里
然后七月份整个就咻就杀下来了
我还记得你自己回去翻六月
反正六月附近那时候的直播
很多人问到我都说很懒很懒
我不太想做不太想做
结果你看就下来了
来
我为什么看起来像刚起床
是因为头发比较乱吗
我最近在练习 练习把头发留长看看会发生什么事
看可不可以当个索尔这样
结果我只会有他的肥肚子
6月开始做单
账面上几乎都是赚钱的
6月开始做单账面赚钱不简单的因为6月是涨然后7月整个下跌
所以代表你有能力去筛选那个行情并且很有耐心可以等待这个是很棒的好不好那我先回来
我刚刚
我刚刚讲的这些
同学说
整理你的好球带
交易记录截图中
挑真正的好球
挑一挑心情很容易烦躁起来
有些单子现在看到
还是会犹豫不决
我跟你说
你在做交易记录的时候
给你一个好方法
就是我不管你打了什么单
你就图形上用两种模式
一个是这种
一个是互换
我画在这边
这样子
互换你大约要画一下
画底部到这边的距离
跟这边到这边的距离
要约略差不多的互换
你就画这样子
然后呢
你就用这样子的截图的模式
这个
这个截图的模式
我去比对
不管你做的什么单子
你就看这两个去比对它
有大概八成像的就给过了
有八成像
你有躲后面
躲在
躲在这个地方
尖尖的
隔壁的
好
八成像这样子的
给过
甚至偶尔没有躲
但是图很美
都给过
好
这样就好
所以你唯一要挑的就是
有像这个图跟没有像这个图
如果你今天是假设有一张单子
你是我一样用这个图
假设是这样子掉下来来到这里
结果你直接摸摸了然后就上去的
虽然你是赚钱的
但是这张图是一个很
风险很高的这种图
简单的说这是一个坏球
只是你刚好打到这个坏球
对方没接好
落地变成安打
大概是这种感觉
这运气好
偶尔就会发生
但这不是一个
一个长线我们该做的事情
这样
所以你就用刚刚我讲的
就是你画两个图去比对
然后呢
好来再来
你说心情容易烦躁起来
因为你想要挑真正的好球
我这边想要帮你把一个想法
拿掉一下
市场上没有那个真正的好球
只有大概是好球
有听到我讲的差别吗你讲的是真正好球你如何定义一定是涨上去还是怎么样才叫真正的好球吗没有我们从头到尾都在做模糊比对
只是这个模糊比对是
已经是尽可能的把这个条件筛选筛选
筛选到可能七成八成的模糊
差不多像
好啦可以了
剩下二三十%有点不像的
那个我们也没办法了
当你把这个想法放宽以后
你会发现好坏球就是这样
就是差不多差不多就灰
差不多就灰
然后你让错误
小小的错去承担这个好坏球
的这个一定要好球的心
注意这件事情
我再讲一次很重要
你用简简单单
轻轻松松的犯错
来去弥补好坏球
没有做到很精准的这个
因为不可能百分之百精准
对吗
那没关系
我就是小错
轻松简单的错
给他
对了
好赚我的
给他
对了赚我的
大概是这样子的逻辑
好不好
所以你说
有些单子会犹豫
当你会犹豫
基本上就不是好球
一个好球的单子
你一秒一看
像我们刚刚看到
那个台子旗的那些店
像刚刚旁边同学不是都说有花仙的
有没有
那些点就是你一秒一看
就这里
那个你看我看大家看
美国的人看
全部都一样
那就是那个点
那种就不会错过
然后如果是你看了一下
你还要犹豫老半天
到底是这里呢
这样画呢
还是这样
你会需要犹豫的都不是好单
简单的这样讲
好不好
再回答这个
台股连跌几天
有些跌深的这样子
现在涨回一些还是没有图
好我们来聊这个
我随便找几个
这个没有涨
这个没有跌深
例如说
我记得是
我现在随便叫
就这些周线
这个也没有跌多少
其实
对啊
我看一下有什么东西可以跌多一点的
这个好
来来来我们就用这个好了这个广达我现在随便挑的好不好我只是在找一个这算跌深吧从400是跌到280应该算蛮深的现在没有图对不对
那我的习惯
我会把你刚刚讲的那些没有图的单子
退一步
然后呢
在更大的刻度
就是我要做日线
我就跑到周线
更大的刻度画出两条线来
就像现在这样子
第一条线在下面
第二条线约略在上面
好
上面的线下面的线
定义出来了以后
我回到我的日线
回到日线我就观察
我就问自己
我要在这个边界
我要用日线图来吃
还是我还要再缩
缩到60分K
你现在就要拿捏
假设你要做日线图
那就是等
因为现在是由下往上撞
等他哪一天
可能出现下面这边
看他撞得怎么样
如果出现尖尖的下引线
哎呦
在这附近
有上去有回来在这附近
我或许就可以开始画出破底翻的样子
也可以
或是干脆走上去一点
你给我好好的往上走
走个10%好了
走到330
然后再跌个几%
跌个几%
跌个几%回来
如果我回来这个地方
好耶
那这也是我的
所以不管哪一个计划
都需要时间
可能需要
短的话可能还要几天
长的话说不定还要半个月都有可能
我就做这样子的计划
那会不会成功
我不知道
但有些人说
我不想等
好那你就用60k
来
进到60k
那60k一样嘛
做同样的规划
要么你是这样
这几根上去
这几根回来
在这里
或是干脆下来
回来这里挣荡
这里测这个地方
看他有没有尖尖的
像这个这种跟着吃
就大概是这种概念
看你要用哪一个刻度这样
好不好
有人问说台子还能追吗
来
我刚刚看到哪里啊
台子还能追吗
你是不是想要反串的
上面他忘记看到哪里了
我讲完这个台子还能追吗
我去抱猫好不好
大家要等我一下
好吗
来台子还能追吗
这个问题
刚好跟今天的主题
其实有关系
好问你啦
老于你说你觉得台子会上去
好那我如果现在追在现在四
43977979
可以吧
那我就问你啦
你是用哪一种等级的角度
哪一个刻度
哪个时间格局来吃这个摊子
如果你是用日线
你现在吃日线
你现在才在问台词能追吗
那你前两天为什么不吃
前三天前四天为什么不吃
因为前三天前四天我不觉得它会涨上来啊
现在长势比较明确了
我觉得这边追比较安全
这个想法可能要拉回来
追真的比较安全吗
当初追这边的人
追在四万八的人
你在四万点的时候问他一下
请问安不安全
他会拿砖头丢你
对不对
那个砖头是他准备要上吊自杀
天下底下用的砖头
他会先拿出来丢你
你懂我意思吗
所以我不觉得要用追的
所以你光追这两个字
其实就
就不需要
就可以拿掉你的字典
那你现在要问的是
如果我没有上车
像我休息这么多天
出国玩
然后又生病
我休息这么多天
我这边
我所有的小纳都空手
我要怎么上车
这就跟我刚刚在计划
那些股票有没有
那些股票
我看到这些地方
我规划
我要这样上车一样
如果他下一次回来这里
哦那我观察
如果他上去了
那就完全上去了
除非他中间又回来
这里接我
但这个我现在都很难去预期
那你说老爷这日线有点久
那就用小10k嘛
那小10k基本上也还是同样一件事
两种格局嘛
一个是上去一个是下去
那还是回到原来的地方去
好不好
好
我先去抱猫
大家给我大概一分钟
我看抓不抓得到
谢谢大家找到貓了
嘿!看到了嗎?看到了嗎?這一隻
這隻現在很舒服的樣子
欸!我好像時間到剛好回來對不對?
這隻,哈囉哈囉
好啦,下來下來下來
來,我們來看
我们来看看行情
不要管猫了好不好
我们来看行情
今天就让他来这边陪我
山花母猫
对呀山花母猫
我刚讲到哪里
来讲今天的课程
来来来
今天的主题是这个
是这个
把它跳到我旁边的架子里面去
逃命波还是创新高
这个等一下我都会来聊
那我今天有一个影片要给大家看一下
就是我有抓好
这是
这是大家看一下
这是我在一天前上架的影片
一天前2026 8月3号
就我昨天录给那个群组同学的影片
那大家来看一下这个地方
那大家听一下
你这边有字幕可以看一下
假突破的很重要的分界
那喜欢做多的我怎么样
我就知道我在接下来这
可能一个小时要杀两个小时要停
可能三个小时吧
那我就知道在7点吧
来我先中断一下
当时我在行情看到这个地方
我第一个就说啊这边我不喜欢
所以那是一大早
8月3号一大早的第一个小时
所以我就说看到这样子其实我不喜欢
我希望他下来所以我下来的感觉这个是小10k我接抓真实的行情讲好了我当时看到的是
这个小时
是这样
这个是我当时看到的东西
所以我心里面希望的是
是把这个缺口给补掉
那如果可以来碰这个地方
可能但是这个地方到底是会在284停住呢
还是会在283停住
还是在28
哪里五停住我都不知道
但是我希望的是把缺口补掉
那我各位
我其实很少讲到缺口
我趁机来聊一下好了
一个缺口的概念
你可以把它当成是压力或支撑的概念
例如说
例如假设现在突然间
收盘了然后到明天一大早的开盘
然后跳到这个地方来
我这样讲解缺口喔
中间是不是有空隙对不对
好 那这个空隙如果他没有到很远
很容易在当天内就补掉
那像我刚刚看那个小娜
刚刚影片中的这个
影片中这个缺口
这个缺口才200点而已
200点对于现在的小娜来说
也不过是一个1%而已
所以假设是一个这样子的缺口
假设他往下跳
当行情由下往上撞这个缺口
把他补掉了的这一瞬间
你心中就要有个底了
什么底
就当做是压力支撑被撞到的概念
就这边画一条压力支撑线
隐形的
然后行情来到这边震荡震荡
差不多了
你就可以把这条隐形的线拿来用
那缺口有两个点
一个缺口有
例如说我跳空在这里
有这一个隐形的点跟这个隐形的点
两条线都可以用
因为毕竟他还是有一个200点的价差
对吧
例如说昨天的那个点
例如说这个
所以当他这边
明确的这样子
把它填满了以后
填满了以后
晚上的美股开盘
是不是填满这边以后
瞬间美股开盘瞬间往下杀
我记得那天的5K
有一个超美的点
我不知道大家记不记得
来这个5K当时有在盘前
有看到的举手这个
你有看到昨天的开盘
你有看到这一瞬间28380这边有看到了有吗那个点
其实你看到了
你又知道这是大科度的边界
这个隔壁这里
其实是一个我们很喜欢的东西
而且哦
这个哦
这个下引线
它够长够大
又带着六万口的成交量
是说这根的确真的很快
因为隔壁这边一下子
它只有晃个两下
可能一两分钟就直接就上去了
但是这个动作
我相信大家知道我们讲的习惯
边界一个点两个点
破尖尖的隔壁
这个是很美的
那只是它真的有点快
这倒是真的
我要讲的只是
这个边界正好是我们早上讲的
那个
那个那个
这个
我用这个画
你看哦
我画在这里
这个地方是不是
这里
这个地方是不是这个缺口的边界的
一个是上边界
一个是下边界这边
有没有
那实际上你知道这个缺口
这根K棒的最后一个价格在哪里
其实这是一根下杀的K棒
所以既然是下杀的K棒的最后一个价格
其实理论上在哪里
是在这
所以他隔天是从这边跳到这边
那只是我们人的视觉上面
会希望填满的是像这样子的缺口
这是我们平常在用视觉上面来看的习惯
这样
好不好
猫咪要出去
好啦,我讓他出去一下
剛剛那聲叫聲就是他要出去
大家等我一下
好,出去出去
拜拜
我之前啊
我之前直播的时候站起来
然后有同学看到我穿短裤的
同学问我说
老鱼你怎么穿这么随便
我在家里啊
他还穿随便啊
对不对
后来
后面EK有呼喚还蛮好做的
对后面那个有
好来那我们先不要再讲昨天
我们来讲的是
在这支影片里面
我在当时看到这样子
我就做计划
上去我不要追
你要么给我往上走
回来吃
要么就给我往下
补缺口
我在画的
这是我影片中画的
所以我希望等到下面出现尖尖的
我再来做
对吧
这个动作不就是出现在美股的这个时间吗
大家懂我的意思吗
所以其实可以事先做好计划
你可以计划市场如果怎么走
我就怎么做
那他没有来那是他的事情
我的计划不会因为这样的改变
我就是专心的做我的计划
来那我们来回答一些问题
这些问题我相信也是
网友们
很多人其实都有这样子的问题
这两个我看到了
我先截起来
等下回答
等我一下
我先回到眼前这一个
价格来到关键边界
我会说等上去再回来会比较好
但有些时候会说
如果上去再下来就不对了
有点搞不清楚这两个要怎么分辨
我们用
看有没有用办法用即时盘
来让我讲解一下
同学的这个我先解起来
有没有同学听得懂这位同学在问的
我先这样画好了
假设这里有个
我就用眼前的图
这里有个干净的边缘
这边好了
那同学希望说
讲解说行情
如果行情来到这边
他没有任何的反弹
没有任何的往上的力道
它一直处在跌多长少
跌多长少
跌多长少的这个角度
来到这个边界
请问你眼前当下
眼前的惯性是往哪里走
往哪里走
往下走
所以我说会等一个上去再回来
什么意思
我要在这个边界等待惯性改变
什么叫惯性改变
来
跌多长少
变成
涨多跌少我现在画的这个蓝色对不起哦我现在画的这个很重要所以他有出现这个涨多跌少以后
我会开始出开始脑袋里会有
哎呦
惯性改变了耶
那我这时候
如果我要从A点做到B点
那我我是不是做在涨多跌少以后的第一个
第一次的从跌多涨少换成涨多跌少的跌少
那我把这边放大
其实它就是这样子
行情就是这样子
涨上来它有能力过这个高
对不对
再回来看是在这里停住
还是说
本来上不去的边界
这个本来上不去的边界
变成由上往下踩
这样也可以
因为它仍然是一个惯性的改变
因为本来的惯性都是
本来的地板变天花板
地板变天花板
一直降下来
结果突然间这个本来下不去的地方
变成上去又回来
这些都会引起我的
那你看
它是不是仍然需要有长多又跌少
由上往下踩
所以我会去看这个东西
所以我会等一个这样子
好不好
但有些时候我会说如果上去再下来就不对
来注意看哦
我就用这个
我用
我很常吃在破底翻的这里
然后我说
我说这边吃了
应该要理论上这里就要出去了
这里要出去了
要这样子出去才对
那如果我吃了以后
后面注意看我现在画的
后面来到这个地方
长了一个长长的上影线
然后在这个地方开始有点往下走
像这样子
像这样子的图
它再回来的这个地方
你就不能用破底翻来看了
因为它整张图
其实已经跟原来的图形是不一样的了
我涂鸦给你看
我刻意用很粗的画笔
我用然后来涂鸦
啊用掉了
本來的破底翻是這樣子對不對
然後行情上去了
尖尖的上去又回來
假設又回來請問這張圖紫色的這張圖跟橘色的破底翻可能前面的行情都是這樣下來
這樣 紫色的跟橘色的那塊一樣嗎?
不一樣耶 他不應該這樣子
喔喔喔 上去了嘛 哈哈
对吧
然后哇塞这瞬间7000口长了
看下多少80
其实也还好啦
是因为我贴在1K里面吧
对啊
所以其实代表好像有人先知道什么事情一样
不过如果这边上去他就不应该回来
他如果不小心杀回来这边
变这样子
那是往下走的几率就很高了
好不好
所以要分辨这个上去再下来
注意看
我再讲一次
例如说这里
上去了
如果这边跌破边界再回来
它就不对
所以你的整个脑袋要重新思考
你要重新的在这边观察下影线
观察新的边界在哪里
观察那个尖尖的在哪里
明天狂涨不用分析
讲真的
我们看川普就好了
川普不是说他要把那个Pelletier他们抓去白宫里面吗
然后看AI什么的
哇大家狂涨最好啊
对不对
我其实很喜欢川普
因为他都会用各种事件
要战争也好
要封闭海峡也好
要克关税也好
然后让股市下跌
然后川普的朋友们都吃饱了
我们大家也可以趁机吃便宜的股票
然后等他觉得吃的差不多了
再喊说不战争了
不克关税了
世界和平
那又奔上去
他最喜欢这样
我这边有讲的应该可以了吧
所以我要讲的就是
一个边界如果被征服了
如果又跌进来
那本来
例如说这个好了
就这里
这条边界如果征服了
对不对
现在待会的兵家必争之地
就是这条线
因为一旦跌进来
所有刚刚买在上面的这些做多的人
每个都赔钱
看我的价格
而这做多的人至少很明显是有8000口的人做多在这里然后底下这里这些这么多人都是只有一点点然后一个八千口
所以如果突然间不行了
这八千口突然间想要倒下来
这个做多要跳车一个空单
做多要跳车两个空单
三个空单四个空单
其实就是这样子啊
对吧
那在这个过程中
你要观察的就只是
市场两边的那个边界这样
ok
然后要如何让量化交易去感受K棒的力道
可以啊你可以用
每分钟
或是每五分钟看你的那个刻度
每五分钟K棒走的距离加上成交量
那你就会有力道的样子了就是
例如说
100口走了
0.5%跟100口走了1%的距离
当然不会只有100口
我只是随便举例
你可以用这样子的方式
用每单位时间去衡量它的加速度
这是可以衡量得出来的
所以如果你有
你去算这一根就可以用你的量化的方式
它单位时间走的距离很远
搭配上成交量
是平常成交量的
我多少多少%以上的
你就可以定义一下嘛
那如果隔壁这边
这个走的距离很快的在
3根5根10根里面
你自己去定义
很快的这根走的距离你就定义好
定义出一个变数锁在那边
20点
那这表我就眼前的眼前是2220到280嘛
这根有60点
那这60点如果在
短期的
可能一根里面就不见
哇
那是不是就代表60点上又60点下
那这不就是一个常上引线的概念吗
那不就是一个吞噬
就是很强的力量出去
但是又很强的力量回来
你就把它写进去
这样应该可以去慢慢
从这个角度去理解那个K棒的力道
好不好
这样OK啦
来今天的主题其实都还没讲到
然后这边要恭喜一位同学
这位同学其实他
我们之前有提到Amazon
然后他也有吃Amazon的股票
很幸运有买到
然后放假回来一看
阿娘威!看到阿娘威真的是好貼切
錢高先出一些
放假錢給自己出一些金
好,這位同學很厲害哦
恭喜同學們
然後這位同學說
之前股市很熱的時候
身邊那些講基本面的朋友講話好秋
直到最近他們開始安靜
都說獲利回土多少多少
結果呢
这位同学专注做基本的动作
莫名其妙的顺
有没有
他说之前那些朋友都会说
就是追高买MU 买Sendisk
那时候大家在追记忆体的时候
追高买都赚钱
然后就会回来嘴他说要等回档
等不到啦这样
然后现在不就到了吗
而且这回档还蛮大的
台湾从48,000跌到4万
还跌破4万
没多久呢一个月而已
对吧
然后这位同学是同一个同学
他就写信给我
我觉得他很厉害
所以我要恭喜他
他厉害是厉害在
他有办法隔绝他的脑袋
不受外面的这些各种
闲言闲语也好
朋友的冷嘲热讽也好
他可以不受那个影响
这个是很棒的
这样好不好
猫咪现在抓门要进来
各位
你觉得要让他进来吗
我听到他在
他在我的门外面
他在抓
然后想要进来
要吗
但是进来他等一下
进来我就不让他出去
我等到我直播结束后
才会让他出去的
来
这两
这张投影片是要回应
今天的主题的第一个
好不好
大家都要是不是
好了
结果说不定是另外一支
來來來
大家說要看
來進來
進來啦
進來
來啦
後面無謀耶
哈哈哈哈不給你出去了
哎呀
再來亮相一次
對他就是這樣子他剛剛還會抓門
那我跟你說你有養貓嗎這邊有人有養貓的嗎貓咪的生理时钟或是狗狗的生理时钟是不是很准啊?我的闹钟 平常射的闹钟是早上的6点15分
然后猫咪他们很厉害喔
他们现在就算我没有调闹钟 就算是礼拜六礼拜天
他一样准时的6点15分 他就喵喵叫喵喵叫 很准
所以我就算想要偷睡一下都不行
做不到
每天就是那个时间就一定要起来
很多人在最近会问说
最近的台子期到底是
涨到这边要逃跑了还是美股
还是以后还会继续涨上去
你知道吗
我不在乎它未来会不会继续涨
不需要知道
你也不可能知道
那是明天的事情
那是后天
那是下礼拜的事情
而且这中间会有多少变化
一下子又战争
一下子又原油
一下子又什么
谁会知道了这么多变化
对吧
那一下日元就突然间涨
突然间跌
好
那我们要做的是
看到跌不下去
就像我们刚刚最一开始
大家看到那个台子期
不是有那个60k的边界吗
对不对
看到跌不下去就试试看
注意看哦
我们其实不需要知道
后来会不会涨
这句话很重要
眼前卖方的力道就比较弱啊
那我就顺着眼前卖方的力道比较弱
我只是照着这个趋势
我就把单子给抱着
就这样而已
包含刚刚我做台子席
我不是画底下斜斜的
上面平平的谁比较强
包含刚刚的这个
完蛋了
今天讲的都会出现
做多的人要小心哦
出现1分K这样子就代表5分K
边界尖尖的这边
所以这边往这里走的几率就很高
然后走到这边也不要直接吃
这个破的几率就很高
你甚至是可以等这个
这样好不好
那你说老鱼现在美股刚开
不用追啊
你在刚开盘去追干嘛
对吧
就慢慢等
等
我等一下说不定要丢笔了
來就看眼前就好
然後到9點半還沒講政客
沒關係反正我都會講到10點這是一個網友然後他寫信給我他其實寫了蠻長一段他說他後來幫要請AI幫他剪短了一下
有一份準時下班情緒穩定的症子
但薪水勉強過活
我看他的年紀
他年紀似乎是蠻年輕的
可能剛畢業沒多久
然後說面對同學
去可能有的人已经出去国外念书的
或是发展很好的赚钱的
跟家里有传统家庭的压抑批判跟情绪勒索
一直想透过交易证明自己改善生活的急迫感
好现况曾经成功又陷入循环
又打爆近期买了这个
好目前这样子练这些
时间分贝重新开始交易后
这位同学我应该会私讯里面
我应该会比较仔细的回应他
我这边先回给大概
这是一个给那些想要透过交易
来辞职把老板辞职的
那个这些人给你的忠告
这一篇
第一个
先不要讨厌你的正职工作
你
我知道大家都想要很快速的从交易
立刻就转职成为全职交易员
对吧
我知道啊
但是这条路没有那么轻松
也没有像大家想象的那么简单
去年或前年
给大家很多错觉
就是股票丢了
眼睛闭着就会赚钱
然后杠杆打开
带一次带两次
带三次带四次都没有关系
眼睛闭着就会赚钱
但是事实证明
那个只是偶尔会出现这样
那不是常态
最近这样子涨涨跌跌
这才是真正的股票市场
那我们已经经历过很多次
我们知道
所以第一个
你先不要讨厌你正直的工作
反而你要很喜欢你正直的工作
因为它是唯一一个
你付出时间
百分之百就会有收入
因为你做的事情
你把这个事情做好
时间过了
每个月就会有固定的薪水
虽然不多
雖然你沒有很喜歡
但它就是固定
你能夠靠它吃得飽
那為什麼吃飽這麼重要因為你如果沒有辦法先把生活上面的那个急迫感拿掉你在交易上面你用再多的钱都没有意义
那个急迫感一直在那边你都赚不到钱
那我是不是看得出来你的急迫感
你想要证明自己给爸爸妈妈看
甚至证明自己给亲戚朋友给以前的同学看
对吧
爸妈会说你做那么久
有没有赚钱
同学会说
我们都已经出国玩好多次
你呢你有没有出去玩
他们可能是善意的问你
但你就觉得他在酸你
有没有
那这个急迫感会一直留在
你的心里面
所以你进到市场以后
你打的每一笔单子
我甚至不用看你的故事
我光看那个单子一打出来
我就知道啊
你在急什么
你是不是想要做给爸爸妈妈看
真的哦
我们之前在改同学作业的时候
因为会
例如说围棋好几个月
都在固定改同一个同学的作业
所以当我们办聚餐的时候
我们不认识大家嘛
聚餐大家都不认识
但是可能同学说
老鱼老鱼我问你一个图
他就把图打出来
然后我就说这是我打的单子
我一看那个单子
你是不是某一位同学
他说对耶
因为他打的单子都有他的感觉
我们改太多就很像
然后通常都是急躁的同学
我们就很有印象
所以我要给所有想要做全职交易员的一个想法
不要一开始就想要当全职交易
这其实我以前聊过
全职交易这件事情是慢慢
他会自己发生的事情
他不能强求
你说不定根本不适合全职交易
有可能啊
我也觉得我不适合全职交易
因为只要我一把交易的那个期待感
那个唯一透过这个赚钱的那个期待感
放进来的时候
我就开始赔钱
我啊
我不是讲别人
我我就会开始赔钱啊
但是当我反而没有什么期待的时候
那个交易就飘着飘着
就会赚钱
屡市不爽
就连现在
到现在我都知道
当我期待感起来的时候
我的单子就会赔钱
就都是这样子
你说我现在有没有资本
有我有资本
我可不可以亏
可以
但是那个期待感跟你有多少资本是没有关系的
你有多少钱都可以有那个期待感
我一有期待感就挂了
就这样
所以我也认为我可能不适合全职交易
对啊
所以它不是一个唯一的解
好不好
你可不可以当一个平常有工作
然后交易一样可以继续做
你就做长线的股票
然后工作做得很开心
你就做开心的啊
这样不是很好吗
对不对
所以其实大家想要的是
全职生活
你讲对的
这位同学说的对
free同学
你要的是
把你的生活给顾好
所以我现在其实
我的重心是摆在我的生活上
把我的家人出去玩
打球
就是我自己的身体
我把这边顾好
交易只是一个
一个旁边的
刺激的副产品
这样子
好不好
所以同学会说
要怎么调试这些
这个可能无法在一次的
直播影片里面就讲到这件事情
我会给这位同学的想法是
是第一个
你要先喜欢你的工作
第二个
一天分配在交易里的时间
不要超过两个小时
老玉两个小时很少
我就是故意要你
把时间拿出去外面
交女朋友也好
看电影也好
游泳吃饭打球也好
把你的社交生活填满
一天只能用两个小时来练交易
让它的重要性降下来
你之所以无法通关
就是因为它太重要了
把重要性降一下
去做一些别的事情
你会发现反而你很好做
真的
你一天可能打个三单赔钱
赔个100 200 300
好 赔钱
你就会很轻松
反正我今天重心都在其他地方
没有就算了
用这种角度去做 相信我 好不好
靠北 到最后面了
真的吗 原来这边就到最后面了
来
交易两小时 看优雅22小时
等一下 22小时你会虚脱 好不好
这边我要再度讲一下
有同学在昨天的这边问我说这种地方问我老鱼 为什么他是问在这里这个文章的底下这里
他问在
我是这篇吗 还是不是
我其实忘记了
好 没关系 我就趁机回答一下这个
趁机回答这个问题好了
刚刚旁边这个我也来回答一下
等一下
来
同学说
分批停利这件事情
很常有时候行情60到200点很常发生
停利的时候
有些单子先收了
后来喷很远会有点凹
或者不收打回去也会凹
我是如何锻炼甘愿跟接受这个课题
课题卡了好久一直跨不去
怎么锻炼
来我跟你说
你看你現在講了兩種
一個是短單你先收
噴出你也oh
長單你先收
你想要打長單
但是拉回來你也oh
你怎麼不兩句話都反過來想
如果你是在短單收了以後
它跌下去
你是不是很棒
短單如果你長單沒有收
剛好像這個
假設長線單沒有收
刚好把这一段给翻出去
翻到刚刚在294这边才收掉
这不是很开心吗
所以你发现你的重点摆在
摆在行情的未来
你摆在未来有没有跟你想的一样
但是我们在例如说你先收单的当下
先收单的当下
你看的是当下
我举个例子像刚刚
刚刚
来
假设你看到这边喷出了
你直接先收29280
你先收了这个单子
你可能打在这边
打在这里
你看到这边收
收了以后
你是有看到后面吗
你没有看到
那你怎么会知道后面在294多少
你不知道
所以你唯一能做的事情是什么
你唯一能做的事情是
接收啊
然后再来如果你当时决定不收单
你打在这个地方你决定不收单
那你就要承受这样子的震荡
然后去拼再一倍的利润出去对吧那拼的成拼不成我不知道但是以今天而言可能让你堵到了而且甚至还更远所以你没有办法
两个都要
所以课题怎么修炼很简单
选一个不能脚踏两条船
一定会翻船
所以你的问题在于
你的心永远都是两边都要
不可能没有两边都要这件事
而且既然你都已经学会分批停曆了
那就是我们讲初一流一的概念
你初一半流一半
那你剩下的怕什么
对不对
我同学说黄金
对啊我最近都没来看
黄金
其实黄金
在4075
4070这附近的60K
还是很标准啊
对吧
然后日线
我好像前两天讲到黄金
我说这个黄金是比较偏多头的
因为我看到上面是偏这样
对
好像就是在这支影片
我讲到黄金
这样
最近我完全没有开
在日本的时候完全没动
我其实想家
完全没动
然后这两天都在不舒服
我是到了今天下午到晚上
就现在这个阶段
我整个精神才好多了
不然我是一直睡
一直睡一直睡
来留一点时间给大家问问题
我现在回答这个
看60k跟5k
一个礼拜最多只能看到一到三次机会
不够仔细
我们来看一下
小SP跟60k
你看了两个商品
5k
那我跟你说
如果看5k
你这边理论上你会吃这附近
对吧
那你说如果你是没有在看盘的
那我真的没有办法
所以你如果是有白天有上班
然后你又会白天有上班
晚上可能又要忙家里的事情
所以你一天能看盘的时间
说不定就美国晚上这两三个小时
然后又要11.2点又要去睡觉
然后睡觉以后
隔天早上起来又要上班
如果是这样子
一个礼拜大概这样子可能没有办法
因为你不太有机会看盘
但如果你是一天
是有能力可以看盘间隔啦加起来大概五个小时到六个小时这样子那理论上你能够做的机会应该不至于到这么少
我通常会这样子
会在一天里面的下午欧洲盘开的时候
就大概就是四点的附近
四点前一些后一些
我会观察一下市场
有没有我们5K可以做的东西
这样子
然后我们的晚餐时间6点7点这附近
我也会看一次
所以我可能
我一天假设
我一天给自己三次的出手机会
白天都要上班
四五点这里如果没有空
我就会看五六点吃饭时间的这一个
然后再下来这个就是在这里
晚上美股开盘这样
那早上的白天时间我不确定
所以这个可能跟你私讯我好了吧
这样好不好
因为我比较可以知道
你要告诉我的是
第一个你的工作时间
你能够看盘的时段在哪里
因为这些都取决于你到底
是不是正常还是真的太少
上面写你有工作有能力看盘
画了两条线很远
如果是这样子
我用来60k
你60K画出来
你是不是都只做60K的边界
对吧
那我跟你说
你在5K里面
你试着把这种
在5K哦
你也可以看得出来边界的地方
你来了就打一天多加一次到两次的这种
5K边界的尖尖的隔壁
你也可以打打看
这样子
有60K早上八九点会有东西会
老于开始讲为何知道昨天美股会涨了吗
有我讲过了
我讲过了
因为这张投影片
因为当时眼前卖的力道比较弱
会不会想打我
因为事实上就是
我们不需要知道会不会涨
但是我当下
当时的眼前我看到的
我做好的计划
如果出现那样子
那肯定就是往这边走
就是这种角度
因为如果出现我的计划
那就代表那个多头是有的
角度都还在
这样啊
好不好
诶 问的那位同学哦
你不要觉得我在敷衍你
你不要觉得我在笑你
不是不是
我是很认真的在跟你讲
讲我们看的
例如说这样讲好了
老鱼如何知道明天美股会跌呢
如果今天的行情
留了一个长上影线
然后变成这样
假设待会这样大量的跌下来
然后让60k变成一个
假设这样子让60k变成一个尖尖的朝上
然后在这里这样
好这样给你出来
来来来
过来
如果是这样子
那我其实看得出来当下多头就弱掉了
又是满足区又是多头弱掉
然后又是日线的
日线的压力区
那这样子的形形下
后面下跌的几率就变高了
我是从当下
然后来看当下遇到什么
甚至例如说前一段时间
美股是不是跌翻了
从30,000多少跌到27,000多
跌翻了对不对
其实跌翻了的那一天
在这里
这个是我很想吃的点
但是我人在日本没吃到
这个点
我光看到这边的这个单子
我就知道哇在一个非常长线的大刻度的满足区
而且是日K的这种地方
还是这样子
有没有
这个地方我很愿意往上读
我的短单是读到这
从274读到281
这是我的短单
长单是读到这里读到293
如果我是读在这个地方的话
那我为什么会知道后面会涨
因为它下不去了
好不好
因為他下不去的
就這個概念而已
就是下不去
做的單子好容易被打聽順
那我跟你說
啊!不要按
各位看一下
貓咪在這裡
剛好看到他嗎
他剛剛在玩我們家麥克風
來
那個
我这样讲好了我看一下好容易被打停损这位同学你试试看
帮我在防守的时候
你不要只做1K或5K的单子
你试着做纯15K的单
你一个防守的距离会比较远
你出手机会会降低一些
但是有做过15K的同学
都会回来称赞15K
好顺好好做
然后会回头去怪以前的自己
做1K做的要死要活的干嘛
15K轻松愉快
虽然一个风险比较大
但是反而好做很多
好不好
怎么做15K
举个例子
假设好了
假设这个地方
当然我现在举例
假设你要做15k
你15k的防守就是
这边你要守到这里去
所以一个防守以这里来讲
大概就要到40点
其实以现在的行情
15k守40点我觉得很正常
前一段时间
行情在3万多点要跌下来的时候
一个5k的防守
就要大概60点
不夸张
那个波动有够大
这样
好不好
昨天喷那么多
来
所以给这个SR同学
我没有办法完全知道
你打单的点
所以假设你都是坐在
坐在标准动作的地方
那其实停损
基本上两次停损
你会吃到一次有东西的单子
所以大概三成的胜率
我觉得是很正常
三成到四成的胜率
是很常见的胜率
那如果你低于这个
那可能就要回头再更细部的去检讨说
我是不是有一些单子是
明明行情还没回来
我就自作主张
例如说有同学喜欢摸在这里
我记得那天有一个同学写信给我
他说他喜欢摸在
他摸在这里
这个
这个点
然后他写信给我问这个东西
他摸在这个真的是
他说他摸在490这边隔壁
好说这里有边界啊
然后有尖尖的啊有隔壁啊
这样就吃了
这个被我念哦来这根K棒的大小谁比较凶这个我们其实讲过很多遍所以如果
有很多同学我光讲这个点他回去检讨一下他的单子
他一看就知道啊原来
我常常被停损是因为我吃在
很凶的K棒
还没停住的时候我就吃了
就像这样子
K棒很凶
空方的力量有这么大
做多只有這樣子
哇
對吧
而且他真的有打破再回來嗎
這種
這種打破再回來的
幾乎不太算
他沒有那種很明確的這樣子
所以他吃在這個
他跟我講是立刻被我敲頭
如果各位是在現場
然後你打出這種單子
我真的會從你背後一頭敲下去
這感覺我打耶
這不是我教的啊 誰教你這樣吃的
對吧
但是很多人是這樣吃
他說只要把他
這種單子拿掉 其實他的整體而言的績效
也好很多耶
對啊
所以
SR同學確實是在1到3分鐘上場
欠揍耶
來我跟你說
你不一定要調到15K
但是你最短只能5k 最短
什么意思 就是你的图 来你的图哦
最短最短只能在5分k
我跟你打勾勾我们做一个约定好不好
今天是8月4号到9月4号以前
你一次都不可以切1k
3分k也不行
你最短就是5k 可以吗 可以跟我打勾吗
可以吗
打勾勾当着所有同学的面
我们来打勾勾约定一下
最短就是5K
不能再细
不能再小
可以吗
可不可以
一个月
就一个月就好
所以我们直播你会来
所以四次的直播
你都要上来报告一下
你这个礼拜的境况
如果
如果你要
你要跟我们讲实话
要跟我们讲谎话
其实我也不知道
这个我们没有办法
但是交易是对自己
我们就跟自己下定捐行
好再也不看1K跟3分K好不好就这样就好连电60K算有圖嗎?我們看一下連電
同學說好對不對?很好很好
60K喔?
還算可以呢?還算可以呢?
我今天看到台積電的60k也看到跟電電一樣的東西
來 各位這是什麼
這是什麼
然後根據現在的美股的樣子
看來明天台積電可能會上去囉
對不對
好不好
所以你在這個地方
也是一個很明顯的就是破地販的樣子
對吧
這樣子
ok
连电差不多啊 连电还有
连电的我觉得稍微比台积电丑一些些
但是还可以接受啦 因为它毕竟还是有一个小互换
跟这个地方 所以大概就是115这附近
所以如果从日线来看 我心里面会有感觉就是
它可能还会需要多一段时间的整理 这样子
如果有上再有下
这一天的这边可能会更美
这样
好不好
那SR同学
你最短看5K
你的大颗度也不用看到日线
跟你无关
大颗度看60就好
所以你就是在60K的边界区域
然后这附近
然后找5K的单子来做
这样就好了
OK
股票60k本来就比较好找到吃点
因为你拿了放大镜更细到一个刻度
那个机会浮现的比率就更多了
日线要等待的时间本来就会比较长
周线的更不用讲
这样
好不好
来2476
还有阳明
我们先看一下2476
日線算互換嗎?
蛤?什麼?
我沒有看,我沒有打錯
2476日線互換
你是要做多對不對?
你是要做多嗎?
還是你要做空?
你想要做多还是做空
你要先告诉我
如果是做多
绝对不会做多在这个位置
然后如果你要讲互换
来来我们刚刚不是有讲吗
互换图长这样子吗
对吧
那我们来玩一下
请问
我把这张图堆叠在
我找不到地方对
我对不起来
这个这个这个
你是问对的股票吗
我没有找到
对不起来
对啊
我没有办法看到互换
阳明
真的吗
来阳明这个的破底翻
底下这边也是漂亮的
没错
同学都会看的
台积电其实要看他明天怎么样
因为例如说台积电来
这个边界
边界在这儿
但是明天如果一开开在这儿
假设一开开在24这里
我要怎么吃
我不好吃
我就只能等他回来这边吃
那你要直接追吗
也可以
如果像这一天一样
追在24又回来到2315
对吧
所以我当然会希望说
可以的话可以开在这边让我长上去
或是干脆开中间
然后往下杀一些些再上去
也可以这样子
所以我要看它开在哪里
因为台积电还有跳空
这没有很好做
所以其实好做的点
其实反而是在今天的尾盘
今天的尾盘这边又接近这条线
又有人在这边等待
这附近
这附近其实相对好吃的多
这样
你要问的是破底翻哪里啊
把图拉开箱那两条线中间
下面那个破底翻哪一个哪一个
那个SAMMY那个同学
你在丢一只股票
明确告诉我一些你要问的问题好不好
因为我现在看不到下面那个破底翻你讲的是哪一个这样我先回答其他的ok8383周线可以分批吃吗
周喔
嗯
嘿嘿嘿嘿
来我跟你讲
这种周线是我不是很喜欢做
我也不会做的周线
为什么会这样讲
因为
这里有个点
这里有个跳空缺口
最近这两天有这样子
对吧
所以对我来讲
在日线的这个框框里面
是一个夹住的地方
周线也夹在下有撑上有压的这个
这里有支撑啊
有压力啊
哇
这个
我不知道耶
我完全
我完全不知道该怎么做这只股票
所以你问我
可以分批慢慢吃了吗
我不会吃
我连碰都不会碰
这样
这样好不好
因为我看不懂
我不知道它的这个动作
如果这个动作是发生在更下缘的东西
例如说这个地方
甚至是假设它是有这样子
一个一个一个一个
这个借我用
这个
如果它是有像这样子的
尖尖的打在这里
注意看像这样子
然后你跟我说这一根以后
老于,周线可以分批慢慢吃的吗?
我会跟你说好东西,赞!可以可以可以,慢慢吃慢慢吃
这样我会给你过
对吧
台子棋在哪一个点进场才安全?
等一下,同学你是新同学吗?
在哪个点进场才安全?
有一个点进场就是你回到三年前的台子期
17000点进场
现在看很安全
如果你吃台湾的2330的台子期
你会觉得跳空有危险
你可以试着去开美股去吃美股的TSM
那是台积电在美股的ADR
它的图就连续很多
因为是交易时间长很多
外资空单怎么看
我不知道
我已经十年以上
没有在看外资流仓的多单或空单或是每日大盘的买卖超外资买超多少卖超多少我已经十年以上没有看了好清爽
所以我从来不看那些
不需要
好不好
不用看
2353周线有停顿小部位试单
我看到什么就聊什么
这一种来来来
同样要看周线试单
这个的周线它落的位置
来 29点多这个位置
它落在周线的重要的互换的边界
同时也是破底盘的边界
还有这些
在这种地方
这位同学说
说这样子要慢慢的试单
这是一个好的动作
我正好是这个案例跟
刚刚前一支股票的案例
是一个很明显两个
一个是我完全不想做
一个是我会觉得
这个是很好的案例
这两个刚好前后摆在这里
各位同学看得出来差别吗
我要感谢旁边这些同学们
我真的觉得
同学被训练的很好
不对
不是被训练
同学其实本来就很厉害
我只是帮你点一下
然后让你的脑袋通了某些东西
同学们在做的这些计划是很棒的计划
超棒的
2353也才刚入场
所以该不会这边买的这些人
都是我们自己人吧
对不对
很好啊
来我们看一下
因为前一周有收缴
前面是呼喚曲等于空单套牢曲讲完了
真的
真的就是这样讲完了
不用那么复杂
嘿对这样就好
而且是当大家都
都觉得啊没有希望的时候
嘿对
就是这种感觉
联雅一直跳高
然后你要问的是什么
我在看哪里
是有什么意思吗?
他的意思就是他一直跳高
大家是不是想要听我讲相声还是讲脱口秀
他的意思就是就是我最近最近可能有什么利多我也不知道反正最近就是买的人很想买但是卖的人不想卖
然后就锁掌停
那我有没有讲出什么故事来
没有
我讲的是真实的现实
今天的事情就是买的很想买
卖的不想卖
然后就变掌停
反过来就变谍停
所以你说有什么故事
坦白讲
是有什么意思吗
没有意思啊
就是叠多了
然后有人买上去
如果你有买在下面
恭喜你
你就继续抱着
那抱到什么时候
如果哪一天它开始出现
开始出现像这样子
像这样子
假设出现像这样子
长在这里
买的很想买
但是卖的更想卖
注意这句话
买的仍然很想买
但是卖的人更想卖
所以图形变成这样子
就跟前几天的这个一样
这样子
长在边界外面的这种
你要小心
如果你有部位要适当的减码
适当在这边获利了结
你有十张就获利了结个五张
这样子
然后剩下的就让它飘
繼續噴沒關係這樣子好不好
3484週K很美
34843481喔
3483 對不起
週K很美我看一下
週K的確尖尖的隔壁
然後呢在哪裡
量好少
我跟你说
量少才好
才代表那个筹码没有人跟你抢
如果量多了
什么时候量多来量多
量多长在外面
尖尖的朝上
你看
这我们才刚刚讲过
量少才好
对吧
但是不要少到那种
一整天没几张的成交量
那个真的不要做
那个真的是太少
你买个五张十张你就变大户了
那就不要做
好不好
那种就不管我们的事
但如果他没有少到那样子
你不要管量
但是你看哦
这个日线代表你可能还可以等个一天
明天看一下这边
还在这边长下影线
你再开始吃都不迟
这样
好吧 我觉得不错啊
所以你要等一下
因为周K的上影线有点长 是真的
所以这一周
如果可以让他长一下周K的下影线
今天是周二嘛
所以你还有三四五
如果有一天下沙
然后有一天长下影线在这边
你在礼拜五再来吃都不迟
因為這樣子你就會是一個
周K長了兩個下影線的周K的隔壁
哦!那又更好做了
好不好
然後
來!還有什麼
2377日線可多嗎?
日線
我有沒有打錯
对啊
日线可多吗
给这位同学
来你应该是新同学哦
我们的做法
你当然要做可以做
但是我们的做法
我们从来都不做在撞墙区域的日线
从来都不做在这里
我们要做的地方是做在
来
前一段时间的维星
在这个地方
我把这张图反过来
你看一下
微星在88块这里
就一路这样涨上去
同样是日线
我把这张图反过来
你一定看得懂我在讲什么
这张图上下颠倒
各位
这是微星这张股票的图
我把它上下颠倒
这是不是我讲日线的高点
上不去日线的高点
如果我在这边的要做多的要不要做
不要我们不喜欢做多在撞墙的地方
这只是一张我把这个价格反过
所以价格就这样过去了
所以日线可多吗
你要追当然可以啊
那只是风险呢
对吧
你当初在这边追的人
这个承受个两三天的回挡
喷出了老鱼赚钱了
如果是用这样子的角度你就追啊
但是如果追了以後沒有成功掉下來哇 那你要怎麼辦你要承受这样子的风险吗你愿意吗如果不愿意 那那就不要追
好不好
6223今天出现十字线出场算不算正确
好像我要下课的呢
对啊
今天有出现十字线出场了
我不晓得你买在哪里
这是第一个
所以我假设你是买在
假设你是摸底摸在4700这里
今天在5900出场了
那我觉得很好啊
这个出场我觉得没有什么问题
因为出现这样子的图
日线出现这样尖尖的
后面往这边走的几率变高了
这样
我不敢说一定或是怎么样
只是说它的几率变高
我很ok啊
那如果你是买在这里
假设你是买在这边
然后跌下来没有走
跑到这里出场
好啦勉强接受
反正回到成本
但如果你是买在这边
跌下来没有走
跌下来没有走在这里出场
那代表你其实
运气好出在这里
你是没有交易计划的
这样好不好
猫咪哦
猫咪跑到我们家旁边有一个沙发
就是那边有一个沙发
他跑到那边去坐着睡觉了
好了
今天好像准备就差不多这样子
华邦店今天涨停
明天也是吗
感觉现在进场容易套
好了
看一下这个
然后呢
今天涨停
明天也是吗
来给这位同学
请你完全放掉明天会不会涨停
甚至连下一秒钟会不会涨还是跌
都不关我们的事
当你放掉这个预测明天的想法以后
你的交易才会从黑白变成彩色的
不然在这个之前
你的交易的世界
你永远在追明天的行情
但是你都忘记去看当下在干嘛
当下这根K棒很强 照道理讲明天要继续走下去
老鱼你才跟我说不要预测明天你现在跟我预测明天 你骗我来喔 我是讲按照现况照道理讲 它要照着这个角度这样走出去
我是从现况来推
知道这个差别吗 差很多喔
我不知道明天怎么样 但是理论上它要照着走
所以如果明天没有照着走
出现这样子的长上影线 就刚刚看到的那些长上影线
你就要做一个抉择啦 走或是不走
对吧
不走你就要接受
不走以后出现各种震荡
那如果走呢
如果走
如果走你就不要管
它后面是不是继续喷啊
你就是要接受这样子的东西
这样好不好
所以不要管
那个未来到底怎么样
你唯一要管的是
我当下做好的计划
现在这里是不是符合我的计划
那我的出场计划在哪里
进场的时候
你就要对于出厂有所想象
你才会有计划
例如说你开一间饮料店
你总是会计划一下
我这个饮料店
人事成本土地成本
租金成本有多少
摊提怎么样
一个月大概要赚到怎么样
才够这个店生活什么的
你总是会有个计划
有出厂计划
对啊
所以跟开店是一样的意思
这样好不好
然后有同学在看PLTR这些
很香啊
这个
这个对不对
它前面很香啊
底下
今天大涨
来
在大涨之前
各位
你们早就看到了
在120这边
明明就有东西下不去
而且这边还是周线的
来
各位
这边界有够明显
但是你不是在這裡吃喔
你120這裡沒有吃,吃154這裡你會很忙喔
不要啦
好嗎?
Intel
底下都很美啊
目前行情都在噴
你不用噴著吃,它會震盪
你等它震盪你會重新找得到邊界
這樣好不好
好啦那前面大家问好多
我就暂时不回答
毕竟时间也差不多了OK我最后跟大家聊一下这是我在我这次去日本我觉得这个地方蛮值得大家去那边耍废看夕阳的
而且我这个还是我用的缩时摄影
我把这个我继续用
我用的缩时摄影这样
我不能点开我要留在这个里面
这样
所以这个是在那个什么
神户有没有
然后往左边开有一个有一个岛叫淡路岛
我不知道大家有没有去过
然后其实你再继续开会开到高松
可以一路开过去
所以我们去那边
然后就说这边的这个夕阳是
这不是宫古岛
这是神户
宫古岛很小
然后神户那个淡路岛
哇 蛮大一个
你Google就有了
你Google神户
你看他左边有一个连接四国的一个大岛
这样子
对啊自驾我已经好几次自驾了
我们前半段坐电车
后半段就坐自驾
市区都是电车啦
因为我觉得市区自驾到时候
我路没有很熟走错就比较麻烦要转来转去
这样
神户是
Kobe
对啊对对对没错
然后这个淡路岛的夕阳
我觉得很漂亮
而且这个我记得我路蛮久的
我就放在那边然后就一边看夕阳
其实这样子我就坐在那边
是說而且那時候還有點風
然後那間餐廳
因為我們在餐廳拍的
這是它的戶外
它裡面是有放冷氣
所以你可以坐在冷氣房裡面
然後這樣慢慢吃個飯
然後看夕陽這樣
我覺得這樣很舒服
這樣
然後
我們就是專門
跑去那邊耍費用的這樣子
所以那天的晚餐
就是完全就是排夕陽晚餐
然後
所以
這不是沖縫
這是神戶
这样子
对啊
OK
所以用这张图来跟大家喊最后的这个咒语
每天都是好棒的一天
开始有感觉
配上很漂亮的音乐
会有好事发生在你我身边
我会尽力帮助身边的人
让他们过得更好
说真的
如果台湾能有更多的人
有这样子的想法
其实各种纷乱会少很多
就是大家吵来吵去
吵那个什么easy way
拜托那什么问题
你的报税软体也是同一个东西
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:30:00 起〕